大事なのはやっぱり基本の気基礎教育が
ものすごく大事です現場で人は育つんです
よだから口先で人を育てることはできない
ですね実を見せるっていうことです青木サ
の人生系哲学100回聞いたら豊かになる
話今回はですね新卒の入社1年目から成果
を出すためにはどうしたらいいですかと
いうことでまある意味逆のこう目線から
行くと上司はじゃあ新卒1年目をうん成果
出させるためにどんな風にこう育てていっ
たらいいのかということについてお聞かせ
いただけますかうんうん
[音楽]
うんまこれは1つね大事なことは人材って
いうのはマインドマインドっていうのは
考え方ですよね人は生きてる人の数だけ
考え方があるんですよだどういう考え方の
人間なのかだよねもちろん採用の段階で
基本的にはまともな考え方の人を選んで
いるんだけど自己中か
それともその利己か理かさらには積極的か
消極的か自責か多化って色々あるじゃない
ですかまず考え方の中でもあの仕事に
対する自信をどう育むかっていうことが
あるのねこの自信っていうのは解釈なん
ですよ4つの自信を育むと会社に対する
絶対の
自信業に対する絶対の自信商品に対する
絶対の自信自分に対する絶対の自信この4
つの自信を育むようなまず関わり方を
するってこですねで特に営業食なんかは
そうなんだけど本当に自分の扱ってる商品
が良いと思わない状態で売ってこいとかっ
てやらしちゃダメなんまず完璧とは言わ
ないけれどもある一定のそのレベル以上の
商品知識を持たせることですでやっぱり
自信を持たせるっていうのは自信を確信
つまりこの商品はお客様の役に立つものな
んだという信念がないと売っていこうと
いう気持ちは起きないじゃないだからその
どうしてもね属性栽培でさっさと育てて
ガンガン数字作って欲しいと思っちゃうの
よでも大事なのはやっぱりちゃんとした
基本の
気このね基礎教育がものすごく大事ですだ
から仕事の基本とマナーと
かそれからお客様に対してどういう風に
その接したら良いのかとか仕事とはどう
いうものなのかとか組織とはどういうもの
なのかとか会社は何を目的にどんな成果を
作ろうとしてるのかとかそういう1つ1つ
のことを丁寧に理解させなきゃいけないよ
ねそして今言った4つの自信を育みながら
あとはマインドノーハウスキルなので
ノウハウはマニュアル化きちっと
マニュアル化しておいてそれを覚えさせる
で覚えさせることに関しては定期的に
テストをする覚えてるかどう
かあのの会社ってどうしても覚えてもらわ
なければならないものに対しては
マニュアル化して覚えてもらうという教育
徹底してますよねそれからあとはまうちの
場合は選択理論という心理学を元にしてる
のでビジネス選択理の能力ね能力検定の3
級を取ってくださいとかそういう風にして
資格制度なんかも盛り込みながらしっかり
と基礎を知識を身につけてもらうだその
よその会社にもその会社の身につけなけれ
ばならないノーハウっていうのがあるので
それをしっかりと文章化しあとは
イントラネットなども使いながら覚えて
もらうっていうことねあとスキルは1番
大事なの現場で育てるってことです
やっぱりうちの場合は同行営業も含め
コンサルタントはねやっぱり先輩
コンサルタントと一緒になって現場で育て
いくうん現場で人は育つんですよだから
口先で人を育てることはできないですね実
を見せるっていうことですうんでやっぱり
3年というプランの中で初年度はこの
レベルまで2年目はこのレベルまで3年目
はこのレベルという風にして段階よった
実現という考え方で決して焦ることなくで
相対的なこう評価ではなくそのある基準に
対して自分がどこまで近づいているのかと
いう風に人と比べさせない方がいい早い人
も遅い人もいろんなタイプがあるのでそう
するとこう人と比較すると自信を落とし
たりなんかこう力の欲求満たされなくなっ
て離職考えたりするので本来1年目でこの
レベルまで行ってればいいんだよと2年目
はこのレベル3年目はこのそれをいかに
早く前で覚えるかは本人の努力だよねとま
そんな風にしてえ育成をしていったら良い
と思いますよねありがとうございますはい
一方でそのま育成ってやっぱりすごく時間
もかかりますしなんて言うんでしょう新人
を即戦力に変えていくってま難しいって
いう風に思ってる方も結構多く
いらっしゃるんじゃないかなって思うん
ですけれども基礎基本をなんかやり続け
てった先に本当にそのちゃんとした戦力に
なってくのってなんかどれぐらいかかるの
かなみたいなうん見通しってどうやって
持ってったらいいん
[音楽]
ですまうちの場合は3年で給料の5倍の荒
利益付加価値を稼げる人材を育てるという
のが目標の指標にしていますそれはその
会社によって色々あると思うんだけどその
指標から逆算をしてどういう商品を扱って
いるのかえどういう風にそれを提案をして
いくのかでチームとしてはパーヘッドと
いう考え方1人あたりの生産性をどういう
風に作っていくのかそれやっぱり経営者が
設計をしてで育成のプランを立ててやって
いくでさっきちょっと触れなかったんだ
けどあの組織って個人の集合体なので個
個人が明確な目的目標を持つということが
成長の実はポイントなんですよ本人がなん
だろう目的目標を明確に持っていると自分
から求めるんですよね求めるから与え
られるわけで求めないのに与えようとして
も猫にコバになっちゃうわけですよ豚に
真珠だから求める心をどうやって育んで
いくかっていうのが人材育成のポイントな
んだよねで求める心作るためにはやっぱり
なるべく会社の中にモデルが多い方がいい
しそれからどうしたらそうなれるのかと
いうその具体的なそのイメージですよね
イメージを一緒になって育んでいけるよう
な時間を後回しにしないで最初の段階で
関わった方がいいですで支出ってすごく
重要なのでやらせてみてあこれちょっと
脂質違うなと不向きだなと思たら武を変え
た方がいいあのね苦手なものをね正しさの
剣を抜いてなんでお前できないんだとそれ
でね追い込むっていうのはやめた方がいい
だやっぱりね本人の願望とそれから本人の
元々持ってる脂質を伸ばすていうことが
大事なんです
[音楽]
よだからアチーブメントの場合はその
1人1人が自分の人生に明確な目的目標を
持てるように研修を通してそういうお
手伝いを社員に対してしていくだからね
発想の転換なんだけど世の中の経営者って
会社があってま経営者があってね会社が
あって社員があってお客様があるとこう
いう考え方なんだよねでも僕は違うんです
よ
会社の経営人があってお客様と社員の両方
をの欲求を満たせるような仕組みづくりを
サーヴァントリーダーシップ支えながら
その新人を育てながらお客様に貢献できる
ような仕組みをどうしたら作れるだろう
かって考えてんです
よこれもちょっとヒントかもしれないです
よねうんだからま人が育つ組織をどうやっ
たら作れるのかぱ良いモデルがたくさんあ
るっていうことマニュアル化するものは
きっちりとマニュアル化してくっていう
ことと現場で人は育てるというこの3つは
どうしても外せないことじゃないかと思い
ますよまあね人を育てるって簡単じゃない
ですよねうんま色々大変なこともあると
思いますけどね是非1つねコメント欄に私
の今のメッセージを聞いた感想よろしくお
願いしますチャンネル登録をまだの方は
どうぞお願いいたし
[音楽]
ます僕はともかく社員を幸せにしたいと
思ってるのでどうしたら幸せになるななる
仕組みが作れるだろうかっていうことを
人事と一緒に考えながら仕組みを改善し
続けて20年経ってるわけですよだから
どこここにも絵に書いた持のようなその
成功のシナリオがあるわけじゃなくてやり
ながら工夫してきたっていうのが現実かな
だそれはでも経営者の覚悟が必要だと思う
やっぱりねま本当に本音で僕には理想が
あるんです
よ本当に僕は社員が大好きなんで社員が
可愛いという気持ちがなかったり大好き
だっていう気持ちがなかったらこんな制度
にはならないと思うだから僕はうちの研修
でも経営者のあり方からやり方あり方を作
るっていうやっぱり社員を愛する心を育む
ような教育を社員教育あの経営者教育し
ますよねそれがないとねコストになっ
ちゃうんですよでもう働きがちょっと
悪かったらすぐなんか首にするみたいな私
考えたことない
からあのこっちから降ったことはないわけ
よ振られっぱなしの人生なのよ本当に
ずっと振られてきましたそのたみに省して
ごめんねで残った子に対して残った子を
絶対にこの残ってよかったと言ってもらえ
の会社作るんだと思って頑張ってきたわけ
うんそれが実態ですよねうんでも世の中で
は事実ねグレートプレスワークスでもこの
ベストカンパニーに9年入ったり事実客観
的な評価でもいい会社にはなってると思う
けど僕の理想からするとこんなもんじゃ
ないですよ実は青木サと出会ってよかった
と青木サとこの期間一緒にアチーブメント
という会社を社会の後期として経営して
良かったと思ってもらえるような経営を僕
はしたいとうんそれは規模じゃなくて
できると思ってるんですようんそれが僕の
だってさ中卒の僕にトップライブで説明会
聞いてよしこの社長と一緒にやろうって
決断してくれたわけじゃんどこの会社でも
行けたにも関わらずAppleでも行けた
わけだからな迷ったぐらいにさでも
Apple切って断ってきたわけじゃん
っていうことはそこに何があったかって
いうと共感なんですよ社会よくしようと
いうそれをやっぱりね継承していきたいの
よ大きな組織にしてうん大きな組織にする
理由は社会献できるからですよだ今回もな
学校で講師やってきたもんなはい嬉しかっ
たろうん子供たちの未来に影響を与える
仕事いくら個人でやっててもそれはでき
ないやっぱり教育委員会とかいろんな
ところに認められながらねやっぱり入って
いくうんだからなんだろう経営って何だろ
うっって言うとやっぱ総合芸術だと僕は
思っているのはやっぱり同期全でなきゃ
だめなんですよだ今日本のね経営僕あの
面接でも言ってるんだけど今回のあの2人
のね新卒の面接の時でも見てるとさ日本
代表するインターネットの採用のね広告の
会社に内定まではいかないけどその最終
面談までの進んでるで僕は言ったわけね
なぜアチーブメント
ばならないのかとその会社の役員にうちの
受行性がこれも言ってあげたんだけど受行
性がうちで学んで社会良くしたいのでその
日本代表する大手のね1に争う会社だから
取引先何千者もあるわけじゃないその広告
人材流動化のでどうしたら社員を幸せに
できるかそれから定着率もっとよくして
会社の中で自己実現でできるような
コンサルティング的なことをやりませんか
とお手伝いしますのでって言ったらそこの
役員がなんて言ったかて言うと全く興味
ないとうちは人が辞めてもらって流動化
するから商売になるんだ
と全く興味ないと一等両断で言われたそれ
でがっくり来ちゃったわけでもこれが英理
主義の企業の実態だとだ僕ははそれは本当
にそうだと思うのよだうちは違うじゃん
やっぱり事前の一手は事後の100点に
まさるとやっぱり教育によって良い情報に
出会うことによってその会社をより良い
会社にして
いけるまだから理念だと思うんだよね目的
に共感した人材で固めてくっていうことが
強い組織を筋肉質の良い組織を作る秘訣だ
なとその風に思うけどねうん